One last photograph.
Many coal miners remained true to traditions,
even as the decades saw dramatic changes in
the industry.
At a miners' association event in November,
they said a final farewell to the community
where the industry has always played a central
role.
It was a moving moment.
"It really hits you hard to realize that it's
all coming to an end.
A lot of the guys have tears in their eyes
right now."
In the heyday of coal mining, there were 163
pits in Germany.
Pit manager Jürgen Kröker closed two of
them.
Prosper-Haniel is his third and last.
"The other day when I was down the shaft I
thought, 'This is probably the last time you'll
be down here with the crew, the last time
you'll come down to the coal face.
The world has really moved on."
Miners will continue to descend the 12 hundred
meters into the earth's bowels here until
the end of next year.
But instead of coal, they'll be bringing up
machines, cables and old iron.
Most of the equipment will end up in Turkey
or China.
Many of the miners are bitter that their machines
are being sold off to competitors who will
end up supplying Germany with cheap imported
coal.
Michael Gerdes is the only miner in the German
parliament, the Bundestag.
He worked in the Bottrop mine for decades
... and believes Germany's move to end the
industry is a big mistake.
We're going to miss German black coal one
day.
The fact that we're no longer producing it
in Germany doesn't mean coal-fired power generation
will cease.
So we'll need black coal from other countries,
and their prices will clearly rise.
And the standards that we introduced here
don't exist in those countries.
The landscape is still marked by winding towers
and coking plants, but other companies also
moved in here long ago.
Bottrop is betting that by developing something
new on the many areas once dominated by mining,
it'll be able to secure jobs for the future.
I'm optimistic, because we have good projects
to further develop areas.
First we'll clean up contaminated old mining
sites, then we'll help new companies set up
here.
It's a big project."
Europe's largest Chamber of Horrors has set
up shop in the old pit's historically listed
laundromat.
A positive investment in the region in the
post-coal age.